hi i'm riya here's some more my favorite
japanese noodles
[Music]
yakisoba is kind of like mac and cheese
for me
it's easy to make you can make a lot of
it and my mom used to make xovar all the
time for my lunch
[Music]
so the first recipe is classic yak
tasty japan is making four different
versions here
basic yaksov is usually noodle cabbage
carrot bean sprout
thinly sliced pork toast with yaksova
sauce which is sweet savory and tangy
all at the same time it's very similar
to okonomiyaki sauce but slightly
thinner
it's kind of like japanese charman
you might only be familiar with the
basic style
but there are a bunch of different way
of making it
the second is salt and lemon i've
started seeing a lot of trend where salt
lemon combination is getting very
popular in japan this is lighter than
the sauce one also yaksova you often
would find on the street
it's very much a japanese street food
you can also find in japan an instant
version so you can just pour hot water
drain the water and add sauce it's kind
of like mulch and ramen but we have this
yaksuba version of that the options are
unlimited the third one is buttakimuji
but it's pork and kimchi pork and kimchi
flavor combination is very popular as
well if you go to an okonomiyaki place
you will see this flavor combination
very often it's a japanese take on more
of korean style dish i feel like it's
more japanese people have started using
kimchi in our daily food so i think it's
kind of a fusion
you can order your favorite vegetables
and protein and make it a little
healthier and
make it fancy
the fourth one is a little bit fancy
with more seafood it has shrimp and
squid it also has a little quail egg
real egg is super easy to find every
grocery store has it pretty much
you might only be familiar with the
basic style but there are a bunch of
different ways to make yaksoba that you
should try
it's easy and simple with proteins and
vegetables nutritious and delicious dish
there is another type of ramen called
skimming the noodle is a little thicker
and it's usually served cold and you
will dip in a hot broth
unlike ramen the noodle is not sitting
on the soup you will take it off a plate
and dip it in the broth the noodle is
soft separated with the soup you dip the
noodle into the soup like sober noodle
but it's a little different in time of
the broth this style is not as popular
as ramen but i feel like it's getting
very popular sometimes if you go to a
restaurant the broth is different and
they get creative a lot of ramen
restaurant will have comment on their
menu so if you like ramen you should
give a try
or try making this recipe at home it's
very easy to make roast is very
condensed and very thick i think it's a
great sama noodle recipe you are now
slapping hot broth out of a bowl like
ramen instead you will have a nice
refreshing cold noodle and
this recipe is also developed by daiki
in tasty japan most of the ramen recipes
are developed by him because he loves
noodles so much this is a different type
of ramen but if you love noodles and you
rub ramen i'm sure you will love this
also there's a trick to make pasta into
ramen flavor noodle so when you're
boiling water add one tablespoon of
baking soda
and add angel hair pasta
and once you cook the noodle it tastes
like ramen noodle
it's a great hack i want to make a video
about it but i haven't had time yet so
here i'm just telling you it now
if you don't have an asian market or
access to ramen noodle just boil a pot
of water and add baking soda and salt
and it that's a trick
[Music]
the last time i had a skimmer it was
haneda airport in tokyo and when i went
to madrid they had hamong on the airport
food court i feel like some airports
stepped up their airport food game
just saying
screaming is very refreshing and it's
very different from ramen if you never
try it please try this recipe i'm sure
you will love it
soba noodle is our tradition to eat
during new year's eve toshikoshi soba
means ear crossing noodles
some people say one of the reason is
this buddhist temples used to give soba
to poor people on new year's and it's
become a tradition to eat on new year's
eve so what i know about this tradition
i saw soba noodle is very easy to
prepare and end of the year it's very
busy
so they want to make a meal something
very quickly and easy i'm not hundred
percent sure what is the origin story if
somebody knows please let me know so one
of our superstitions is so far it's long
so it's like longevity of life to eat
soba noodle it's kind of good luck thing
if you eat long soba noodles you will
have a longer life there's a bunch of
different superstitions about it too
sofa noodles are made with buckwheat so
it's gluten free it has no gluten in it
so it's very difficult to make a home
you need a skill to make soba
if you want to know more about making
soba noodles watch alvin's video the art
of making soba noodles it's very
beautiful video
you can also purchase the dried soba
noodle in the asian market or some
grocery stores
so one of the topping in the video is
called kaki again
it's type of tempura it's like veggie
medley bunch of different vegetables
coated with tempura butter and fried
usually you also include onion and
carrots soda is usually either sub hot
or cold depending on the weather or your
mood koda soba comes with dipping sauce
sort of like tsukemen noodle
and warm soba comes submerged in soup
more like a ramen or udon yaksoda also
has soda in their name but it's
completely different ingredients so yaki
means pan fried for yakisoba soba is
baku noodle last time i had a soba
noodle i went with wasa team in tokyo
someone requested soba and it turns out
they're a famous sober shop nearby and
we went but we waited for 30 minutes but
it was really good totally worth it i
also ate soba noodles when we shot in
new york i like eating soba noodles in
the summer time usually cold because
it's refreshing and light for the winter
time i like warm soba noodles i usually
will eat soba noodles for new year's eve
it's a great way to connect my culture
and my tradition in my current life in
l.a
ramen is very popular fast food in japan
and i think it's getting more popular in
the states as well
everyone loves ramen right
i feel like in here the popular broth is
usually tonkotsu ramen and tonkotsu is
made with pork so it's a little heavy to
me so whenever i go back to japan i
always eat my favorite style which is
shoyu which is soy sauce based
or salt which is chicken broth based
because it's a little lighter than
tonkotsu i also love soft boiled egg in
ramen and it's very easy to make
you just boil water
and put the egg in it and wait for six
to seven minutes this ramen recipe is
developed by daiki in tasty japan and
i'm so glad that he made this video so i
can make a home
and another popular flavor is miso ramen
miso ramen is miso based broth it's very
good sometimes it comes with mison
butter and sometimes it's a little spicy
my favorite toppings for ramen is memma
which is bamboo shoot
kind of has a little crunchy texture to
it so it gives a nice texture into ramen
because ramen is usually soft it's
considered like
slow fast food because it takes a long
time to make it but it's very fast to
serve
you can find ramen shop easily in la but
if you want to make a home there is
ramen noodles you can find in asian
grocery stores it usually comes with
browse too
[Music]
salman has a very very long history as
long as i can remember i've been eating
so man during summertime
it's usually soft cold and it's a really
great noodle
so made something that i feel like a lot
of non-japanese people wouldn't
recognize but this is staple dish in
japan during the summer time i can't
even remember how many times i ate so
many for my lunch
it's very affordable and everyone can
make a home
this is something you will usually see
at restaurants it's something you will
see in home cooking
it's super easy and it only takes two to
three minutes to boil
my mom makes a lot during summer time
it's very refreshing it's a very quick
meal to fix so i think it's a noodle for
busy people some is very thin and it's
also dried so it has a good shelf life
usually it's soft which meant to you so
simple so man it's just meant to you
with scallion for this tasty japan video
they made four different varieties of
dipping sauce the most fun memory about
salmon that i have again it's during
summer camp in japan we make a slide
made out of bamboo so you cut bamboo in
half and remove all the segments so you
are making giant long slide
then you pour water and slide the
something along with it and you're gonna
catch the salmon with your chopsticks
i'm really good at picking so many
noodles
i don't know so it's a little bit tricky
because some is sliding in front of you
so you have to catch it very quickly but
i was very good at it also during the
summer camp we made a dipping cup and
bamboo chopsticks
that style of salmon is called nagashi
salman
it's just like a very fun activity you
can make slide and playing with noodles
i think you can also find those kind of
restaurant in japan it's really cool i
wanted to recreate that experience here
with hitomi from nifty
who is my work wife
we've been talking about for years but
we haven't executed it we should really
do it and make a video out of it
for this recipe one of the ingredients
is umeboshi which is like japanese
pickled plum
it's super sour but it's very addictive
for me when i think about umeboshi it's
like when you look at lemon and use
salive or your mouth feels a little
strange
we use it for rice balls and noodles
especially with cold noodles i think it
gives a nice kick to the noodle dish
also grated radish and umeboshi it's a
golden combination
it's like pork and kimchi and peanut
butter and jelly
umeboshi and grated radish is a great
flavor combination that has been used
for a very long time
[Music]
have you had swami before if you have
let me know if you haven't go try it
make a home and tell me what you think
this is a recipe for cold udon it uses
eggplant and tomato so it's more for
like summer
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
[Applause]
i love eggplant and it's so good so in
the summer time in japan it's very humid
and super hot
so this is the perfect dish for the kind
of summer
[Applause]
[Music]
the block it uses is meant to you meant
to you it's soy sauce based with dashi
and it's a kind of dipping sauce
[Music]
you can use it for a lot of dishes like
salmon and dipping sauce for tempura
man means noodle and to you is dipping
sauce
this concentrated pre-made sauce is used
mainly for like various different kind
of noodley sheets
[Music]
[Applause]
you can make it from scratch but it's
very easy to find in a grocery store and
i think you can find it in asian grocery
store in the u.s
if you want to make it from scratch you
can make it with dashi and soy sauce and
milling
but if you use mint to you you can make
udon on a whim
[Music]
the last time i made udon for a video it
was beefudong and kitsune udon but this
one is different because it is for
summer boudon
[Music]
so this one is different because it's
not served hot and uses different
ingredients like summer vegetable
[Music]
like yak soba you can experiment with it
maybe you can make italian udon i've
seen carbonara udon before
udon is like a blank canvas so
experiment with it and experiment with
your favorite flavors and the
ingredients and make your own udon
[Music]
you